[Music]
more taco for Cody at a movie activity
[Music]
here we are on a nice sunny winter's day
on the south bank of the coyote River
the object of our endeavors will still
link the library and the Main Street
with the river bank lots of boardwalk
seating areas for children to fish and
the whole thing is just unfinished and
the grass deters is down and when that
grows the project will be finished and
of course the whole thing complement our
terraces across the river in front of
Judge proposed new scheme so this month
all about the waterfront development
here in quiet boys as I already
mentioned a lots already been completed
and it's starting to look really good
next up the construction is the
boardwalk and seating area on the north
bank of the river Kevin Dwyer is the
landscape architect has been working on
the design so Kevin can you tell us
what's happening this part of the river
just behind us here is going to be a
private development hospitality retail
and fronting there is going to be a
boardwalk that links the town center
across the front of the redevelopment
and down towards riverbank walkways
fernsley December boardwalk as a series
of concrete terraces were built into the
seeding it leads down to the top of the
riverbank and that will be a really nice
space people to come down have the alone
to have a cup of coffee and interact
more with the river and what are some of
the challenges that you're facing of
this project to had to integrate our
design with the design of the private
development and also that the rebuild of
top bank wall by weekend and it's just
the timing of that and getting the
design working together have probably
been the biggest challenge so far
construction should begin later this
year and is expected to be completed in
2018 work also continues with local
developer GPS on a proposed riverfront
shopping and dining complex preliminary
designs are complete with a micro
brewery and bar proposed to the main
container the design of the building
will allow visitors to experience the
brewing process while enjoying food and
views of the world as part of the
riverfront enhancement we've placed a
new information panel opposite the
library this is one more way that the
local community can keep up to date with
the latest developments currently we are
seeking feedback on 2 loading options
for access to the new Sport and
Recreation Reserve and the Caillou East
regeneration area an option one test
Street remains open to access the
reserve rural area and private property
option 2 is an alternative where Cass
Street is closed to vehicles at the
entrance to the reserve Angelis Street
was reinstated we'd love to hear what
option you fulfill next update will be
met in some toy for students who have
big ideas for the regeneration and
looking at the ways local youth can
heavily fail for more information about
the regeneration visit any council
service center or Waimakariri dot govt
tnz ford slash regeneration
[Music]